victim's name is Leo copernixer
seems he's killed in the costume story
[Music]
and then he was deposited here
staged so to speak
how long could you intend to hold it all
hostage or is that the idea gather all
the suspects and interrogate each of us
in turn until the mystery Soul Marvin
coconarus overrated playwright
celebrated here right
I'm so sorry sir I can't read my own
hand right now
[Music]
there was an incident
I'll kill you it's as good as a
confession it's not jumps and
conclusions cancel
what do we have here it's working late
huh
he kills copernic to hush up the affair
case closed I'm doing it again aren't
you sir jump into conclusions yeah
a little bit you've never heard did
Richard attachment a real life detective
I understand that you came to blows
tonight in question
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so what did he do that made you
suspicious it wasn't so much what he did
it was more the way he did it how did he
do it sort of
suspiciously right
[Music]